we are at a turning point in our history
as you know there is a growing
disrespect for government it is a crisis
of confidence we can see this crisis in
the growing doubt about the meaning of
our own lives and in the loss of a unity
of purpose for our nation
we always believed that we were part of
a great movement of humanity itself
involved in the search for freedom we've
always believed that the days of our
children would be better than our own
but we've discovered that only things
and consuming things does not satisfy
our longing for meaning wow he is so
screwed
it's over for him I thought that was
beautiful
stop thinking that you know everything
that's going on no I do
I just think that you know having your
heart broken is a tremendous way to
learn about the world I see the shapes
I see this sure this is the really hard
part and then it gets better and then it
gets hard again Jesus you're happy
seriously look wondering if you're happy
it's a great shortcut to just being
depressed